like I've been saying night after night
a brand-new far-left radicalism is now
gripping the socialist Democratic Party
in this country they want to abolish ice
open borders baseless smear jobs the new
left committed to destroying the
president and his agenda and in the
process that would mean your prosperity
at all cost that is not one of their
priorities joining us now to talk about
this and much more I call them the great
one the host of the number one show
Sunday night's 10:00 Eastern here on Fox
life liberty and Levin ah the great one
thank me listen we got a lot going on in
this country we got a rush to judgment
look at BuzzFeed we've got a push Nancy
Pelosi can't even sit down she's so
pulled to the left by her party the
president is given on daca and dreamers
everything they said they wanted they
still won't sit down with him then
you've got a lot of Democrats and we'll
see more during the presidential
campaign wanting 70% taxes and
confiscation and redistribution of
wealth what do you make of it all well
what a mess
let me start with the media poll after
poll survey after survey shows that the
media are liberal and Democrat and they
don't disappoint liberals and Democrats
they've ax we have a packed media where
the groupthink mentality and I wrote
this down before I came here there are
no uniform binding standards among news
outlets no clear line between news and
opinion this opinion show I give an
opinion you give it opinion that's clear
but news is different isn't it no
Universal Rules of Professional Conduct
for journalists that apply the lawyers
and doctors and electricians and
plumbers and so forth nothing no
particular experience required Chuck
Todd Chris Cuomo Stefan optics perience
are as democrat hacks no commitment to
objectivity and that's the bottom line
no commitment to truth-telling
the result is old-fashioned yellow
journalism scandalous sensational
intellectually corrupt so what we have
now is the Fourth Estate has become the
fifth column
mass media in this country they were
committed to Hillary Clinton's election
now
committed to ousted Ahnold Trump every
single day they're sloppy they miss
rapport they don't care they figure
they'll throw out an apology if they
must they try to destroy the president
his family anybody associated with him
his staff Kavanagh anything they have
never treated Liberal Democrats as well
give you a perfect example we want 10
years of Donald Trump's income taxes
well I want 10 years of the Pelosi's
income taxes they're multimillionaires
she's the Speaker of the House no
legislation or appropriation gets
through without her how come the media
don't call for ten years of hers and how
about Dianne Feinstein all the
investments that she and her husband
have made in Red China we don't have a
China Special Counsel investigation to
talk about collusion and the media
promote the progressive agenda climate
change open borders big government and
of course every millennial is supposed
to be Alexandria Ocasio Cortes I don't
know any millennial that's a Marxist
like she is I know Millennials who
volunteered to serve in the military who
are police officers who are firefighters
who are doing great things for this
country every millennial is not a
radical nutjob going through the
socialist talking points now her she we
got to get rid of these billionaires I'm
happy Soros stars and sofa but let's
talk the truth it's the American Dream
not the Soviet dream John Rockefeller
was supposed to hate him thanks to him
we have energy natural gas and oil he
became a multi billionaire so what John
Walton we a Walmart where people can get
things at a decent price and they employ
tens of thousands of average Americans
great the family's worth billions
so what Weyerhaeuser you like toilet
paper you like writing paper you can
thank Weyerhaeuser Bill Gates lefty
Microsoft revolutionized computers
Andrew Carnegie made the production of
Steel possible that we use today Jeff
Bezos I'm no fan of this guy but change
completely how we buy Andrew Mellon
finance the ability for us to have
electricity in every home Henry for I
can go on or not now multi-billionaires
what has Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
created any job part-time job how about
Bernie Sanders what have they created so
where's all this money going to go 70
percent tax bracket who's going to
decide who gets what the Department of
Agriculture the Department of Energy the
EPA these people waste a hundred and
twenty five billion dollars a year
according to the GAO Americans do not
like big authoritarian centralized
government and two million bureaucrats
pushing them around so why do we confer
health care upon them and what does she
know exactly nothing go to the
supermarket there's capitalism 20
different types of bread 30 different
types of wine from all over the world
five different types of fish I can't
even tell what fish market look at all
the different things you get we live
better then kings and queens lived 150
and 200 years ago look at all the things
around you that's created by capitalism
capitalism and freedom individualism the
American people they're about government
government power power edicts Fiats
that's what she's all about and is
Ocasio Cortez
please come on my Fox show on Sunday I
want to talk to you I want to talk to
you about capitalism versus Marxism and
socialism I want to talk to you about
some of your ideas I know you go to
these slobbering interviews and so forth
I promise to be respectful have enough
guts and enough intelligence because my
theory Sean Hannity is this she is a
media creation that's all she is
and let's some conservatives who will
treat her with respect
interview her I would request an
interview a great one you'd better get
it in in the next 12 years because she
said the world is going to end I wish
you a lot of luck in that endeavor and
I'd love to see that interview I think
that was one of your finest monologues
you've ever given on this show about
what is the greatest economic system
that has created more freedom more
opportunity more wealth than anyone ever
imagined
we can compare it to those countries
that have chosen the path some radicals
now want to take us down great one will
watch Sunday night 10:00 p.m. life
liberty Levin you don't want to miss it